je manque une émission france c'est vrai
une autre manifestation cet après midi
14h30 à paris de montparnasse à la
bastille des mouvements de femmes et
sans doute tourner pour manifester
pardon leur satisfaction que liv et gels
interruption volontaire de grossesse
soit remboursée mais aussi parce
qu'elles semblent craindre que le budget
affecté par l'état à ce remboursement ne
soit chaque année à la merci d'un vote
par ailleurs pour elle toute référence à
la loi de 1920 doit disparaître du code
pénal il n'y a presque plus d'un siècle
que les femmes manifestent pour le droit
à la contraception à l'avortement
sylvie marion et olga baïder poliakov
font le récit de ce long combat
il en aura fallu des cris des larmes des
morts des manifestations et des
moqueries et des brimades et des
sanctions pour que les femmes au cours
du siècle écoulé obtiennent enfin qu'un
gouvernement le reconnaissent le droit
de choisir en toute sérénité
le moment de leur maternité
un homme prêtre anglican malthus
préconise publiquement en 1825 la
limitation des naissances pour éviter
dit-il aux classes laborieuses
d'engendrer un excellent enfants pauvres
les néo malthusiens hommes et femmes
même le combat contre les revanchards de
1870 qui veulent beaucoup d'enfants pour
les envoyer plus tard au front jeanne
imbert antinataliste militante fera
plusieurs fois de la prison pour
propagande anticonceptionnelle deux ans
après la première guerre mondiale les
natalistes utilise le contexte politique
et économique pour mettre en place la
loi de 1920 la contraception y est
assimilée à une provocation à
l'avortement déjà punissables d'amande
ou de prison depuis le code napoléon en
1923 le crime d'avortement devient un
délit dans les pays anglo saxons le
beauf contrôle se développe librement
les françaises et vivant à londres
les pauvres font beaucoup d'enfants ou
meurt une aiguille à tricoter dans
l'hyper u ce jeune médecin jean d'alsace
bravent la loi et ouvre en 1935 le
premier dispensaire populaire de birth
control 1939 1944 vichy premier code de
la famille la loi de 1942 à 6000
l'avortement est un crime contre la
sûreté de l'état
c'est la chasse au faisan d'ange une
blanchisseuse marie-louise giro est
condamné à mort et guillotiné l'été 1943
il y à peine 40 ans de cela
marie-andrée lagroye vais y aller étudie
pendant dix ans les centres de birth
control américain est créée la maternité
heureuse qui deviendra en 1958 le
planning familial
les militants du planning ne cesse de
diffuser la contraception alors les
politiciens reprennent la chose à leur
compte un député lucien neuwirth veut
modifier la loi de 1920 mais la loi qui
porte son nom en 1967 livre la
contraception au seul pouvoir médical
son remboursement par la sécurité
sociale pas fortuit la sexualité
descendent dans la rue et s'inscrit sur
les murs 1970 naissance du mouvement
libération des femmes
1971 un manifeste circulent le nouvel
observateur publie 343 femmes s'accuse
du délit d'avortement on les appelle les
343 [ __ ]
de nombreuses personnalités parmi elles
1972 marie-claire 17 ans est poursuivi
devant le tribunal de bobigny avocats
disent à l'ennemi qui crée le mouvement
choisir 1973 331 médecin publie aussi un
manifeste nous avons pratiqué des
avortements inculpé nous si vous l'osez
pour la liberté de l'avortement
cela veut dire que chacun puisse décider
en fonction de ses propres convictions
en fonction de sa propre situation que
tout fut levée de boucliers des tenants
de l'ordre établi
le docteur le jeune du mouvement laissez
les vivre alertent les pouvoirs publics
de quoi s'appuient style et s'accusent
d'avoir changé de camp et d'être
maintenant non plus du côté des malades
non plus du côté des hommes
mais du côté de l'ama 73 encore création
du mlac mouvement pour la libération de
l'avortement et de la contraception
ces militants pratiquent des
interruptions de grossesse sans médecin
1975 l'assemblée nationale adopte une
loi provisoire dépénalisant
partiellement l'avortement pour une
période de cinq ans on parle désormais
10 vg interruption volontaire de
grossesse
la volonté mais aussi le sexe du
ministre de la santé simone veil y est
pour beaucoup
6 octobre 79 à la veille des cinq ans
écoulés pour la première fois en france
en dehors de toute organisation 59
femmes descendent dans la rue
elle réclame le remboursement de l'ibg
par la sécurité sociale et dénonce les
médecins qui refusent de le pratiquer
novembre 79
la loi est votée définitivement elle
n'est pas améliorer la lutte continue
1982 il aura fallu attendre encore trois
ans pour que le gouvernement actuel
promettent enfin le remboursement de
l'ibg par la sécurité sociale mais les
femmes descendre on est au moins encore
dans la roue tout à l'heure pour que
distel cette promesse ne soit pas une
nouvelle fois bradés
parallèlement cette manifestation sont
pour une pour la suite